Let's see, let's start from the beginning
Well, death is the end, so I'm going to the palace, so I'll die with a single blow for the sake of my beauty
Are you making fun of me
?  Say
[music]
I was told by the boss that he would know that I had instigated the installation, so I
had no choice but
to put ani on from the 9-minute weapon.
Yeah, it's definitely a good idea Yeah, let's have a bit of the charm of a tight-fitting car
Huaaaaah Pure Yume Kana Oooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo
I'm worthy of death